[Music]
in just a prank bro news Wow bro chill
I'm just kidding
spend by I know kungfu a mother is being
investigated after a facebook video
shows her flushing her son's head in the
toilet which is called a swirl we did
parties oh yeah you were okay with it
though did it feel kind of good on your
hair a little bit on your scalp as the
kids head big enough to get flushed down
holds the kid so the kid is oh I think
you safe I hope so I didn't the law with
the toilet school crying I'm gonna show
you this video just another way to wash
hair right or dirty it won some
countries they can lick it they wish
they could use the toilet as a as a
swirl as optimistic I like some
countries that with the salons wish they
had the apparatus in some countries the
water so damn black they wish that that
toilet water was theirs oh yeah oh [ __ ]
laughing even harm bar though he's
laughing right yeah he's probably a
little [ __ ] but still that's weird so
this video the mom she shared it to a
friend of hers and then that friend of
her shared it to another friend and then
that friend posted it up any went viral
so many friends and friends she's like I
know we're cool but then they're friends
like I know this girl from work is cool
and then what happened oh my can you
keep a secret
yeah and then you tell your other person
okay but don't no one can keep secret no
one I can know but what if it's really
juicy and it just wants to come out no
then that's not a secret anymore yeah
good I was testing you
what if it's like hey geo don't tell
anybody but I I hit a baby one time I
hit a baby your head I know I hit uh
well then we got I gotta talk about that
a little bit more as you hit this baby
she tells people secrets as I say to
people like I knew it
tell me the secret and I'll tell you if
I can keep it or not I tell you
tell me the full secret in October
keeper he said it differently he said
literally what I tell us I say that or
do you see the full secret love the
whole thing cuz then he goes hey can I
tell you secret and you promise you
won't get mad you forgot that part and
then I go well Tommy the secret first
and then I'll tell you if I all get
madder now boys it was better with Bart
seven I'm sorry yeah it was fun [ __ ] is
easier guys's friend that's why I liked
it better with from you tears oh really
even though Bart said it first
go stick together I did it copy mine was
original first smile is original right
it's different context this is revenge
for Steven Nikki and finicky and Steven
on Steven think you're thinking revenge
so the moms she is saying that it sounds
like he's hysterically crying but he's
not he's crying and laughing at the same
time and then after the video was done
and he said let's do it again but people
are like you know chopped detective
services and everything they're looking
into this he didn't even look like he
got wet Child Protective Services or the
Department of Children and Family I mean
it is [ __ ] psychological [ __ ]
right like the mall dude yeah it is it's
not as Extreme as a [ __ ] you went
through and you can never use your
lifestyle what aren't you see I'm just
saying like his head didn't even touch
the toilet it was like they're barely
dipped but it alpha hair just very
barely [ __ ] tipped it yeah but that's
just how it seems that's how it's you do
what you really would call chopping
services if you saw someone giving a kid
a swirly no but if you thought that the
kid was crying and saying cuz he was
saying no I would have just been like
why can't you be a normal mom and spank
your kid does a kid cry during a
spanking yes does it does that mean
Child Protective Services my opinion no
no I don't know this is Caitlyn the mom
this takes place in Florida by the way
mom Oh
mom and even notice that man's just
saying that she's not an abusive mother
and that people are just taking this too
far oh and she's also receiving death
threats who was recording death threats
is such a powerful anymore because
everyone gives death threats right yeah
I mean I get it some parents just have
to get creative because then you have
such a bastard child that like calls you
on all your bluffs you know in the Gihon
you're not gonna nail it and then you're
like alright little [ __ ] and then you
put their head in the [ __ ] toilet and
they're like oh [ __ ] mom actually this
time good I think she's following the
law she's like I'm not gonna hit my kids
but I will swirly them it could be that
kid that keeps peeing outside of the
toilet and the moms like if you pee
outside one more time I'll show you
where the toilet living I pee in the
toilet you pee in the toilet he admitted
that he was [ __ ] holding tight he was
taking a piss and then tightly hit your
dick and there was almost Isis Falls
yeah thank you sure clean it up look you
didn't even clean it up properly because
I'm using the bathroom and then you know
the you don't even know the name of it
scrubber I don't really use it uh so I
have it like in this nice decorative
thing so it doesn't look all [ __ ]
disgusting and out in the open
mom and that's all full of pee splashes
do you how do you know even the toilet
the top of it had like you built the
toilet with those magazines and stuff
yes all that that was pissed on I'm like
this mother [ __ ] knows my dad
definitely not as long as guys are using
the toilet there's just gonna be pee
splash everywhere like my friend's mom
was so [ __ ] hardcore about that [ __ ]
she made all the boys at the house sit
down to pee and when I came over to pee
she's I was like can I use the bathroom
and she goes you know everybody in this
house sits down to pee and you got to do
it too and I'm like what and she's young
and peeing she's like knocking on the
door and she's like you better be was
sitting down and
Wow nobody's doing that they're like
yeah right mom and they're just [ __ ]
doing their [ __ ] well it's because you
don't really know how your [ __ ] is
feeling that day what
sometimes it's feeling kind of tight
right then it comes out kind of
streaming it's kind of warm and it feels
loose and it's like nice and
concentrated yeah yeah in the morning
when you pee and it goes like double
spring coil that's this morning it went
this way
yeah the way this are for you guys to
just sit down it's hard you know sit
down
yep yeah absolutely
just a lot of work there's pit splashes
all over our bathroom too and I've just
asked Casey I'm like is it really just
that is it here is it Isaac I be your
perfect little boy I think does not use
our bathroom
I don't know how do you know he's not
sneaking in speaking of the urinal you
guys would piss all over the place if
you had like I've seen pee at the top of
public sees me a door handle this
problem if we had a urinal at home I
think it would solve it a little bit
more would it back you know I've even
sat down to pee and then my [ __ ] pee
went through the the seat in the bowl
that happened to me before the media in
it [ __ ] when can't you hold it like
hold it this way you're living it gladly
you just don't know you just throw that
it's pulling it straight and then and
then it went all over my sock and what
can you answer my question cuz I might
have a solution what Lola how about you
or no yes a lot there so I sure know
there's pee all over the floor on your
nose it doesn't work when we take our
dick out we don't know what's gonna
happen we don't know it's a wild animal
like we got a thumb on it but we don't
yeah that's what it's like that's what
it's like I thought a urinal for a
little toddler kid so you could get with
those and you can pee in that thank you
I'll get a life size line huh you don't
know what it's like to be a man in the
constant woman punishment oh we don't
know what I'll try to help you but
you're not listening to my questions all
right sometimes you think it's pointed
straight
and it goes crooked there we go no
urinals getting wrecked as [ __ ] just
like anything else it doesn't work
no so then I have to invent something
like a [ __ ] pot of some sort that
like both top-down you stick your [ __ ]
in there not like I'm sure all the
scientists of the world who haven't told
you'll be the one to solve is you the
scientists have been working on this for
my friend dude you know I'm just trying
to get you back for the for the goof for
this evening
you know what would work though if there
was a vacuum and it goes they just start
sucking so you piss and in the air
which just starts on to you buddy
so somebody he's disgusting no here's
somebody reasonable with logic talking
right now hold on nah he just wants to
jack off without using his health I'm
auntie you know that did NASA did you
know that NASA does that in space oh
really yes
they already solved it the scientists of
the world are it's all the poop out no
they suck the b-two we talked about
maybe there's dropper to pee in the
[ __ ] in the ISS up there so well it
goes like when you turn it or thicken a
thing and then like vacuums are all put
in a hose see so that there you go
scientists won't have tackle the problem
well we could pee in the backyard or you
just pee in the backyard you know and
it'll splash anything inside for your
kilograms being a bath you got pee on
the mulch gotta pee on the mall
what if they just do that at the public
bathrooms yeah you can't use their
bathrooms anymore yeah that minute you
and the dogs all piss in the same area I
don't mind I did a couple times your
backyard smelling what at our house I
think so I'm not sure what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
I know that they're like right there the
kiddos during the time versus my
backyard is gonna start smelling you
know they're in the hot tub you gotta
pee no good I think
have to separate you can keep the house
we're living at another somewhere else
why is this you're so disgusting do what
I'm rich as [ __ ] you I'm gonna buy your
guys house I'm just gonna use it as
toilet your beautiful family home will
just be my toilet this is my temporary
home I'm not attached to this place I'll
buy your do-over never leaves my toilet
they're gonna be so much it's time to
let the dogs out to pee and milla night
you know either [ __ ] doggy door what
are you talking about this is I think
before the doll your door we installed
it right away I don't know what is
happening right now it's on the dirt I
almost bought the [ __ ] on your Bush gee
oh yeah that's an emergency dude that's
okay emergence of those like pack
mentality pings you know like what you
see like $3.00 you with the dogs cousins
are dropping off here together like what
have you ever peed in your backyard
never Tiffany never barked Peter your
burger you peed in our backyard no
you're a backyard oh I'm yours in my
backyard we're not old are you that nice
to pee out in when you feel the way oh
it was weird like there was gonna be
spiders crawling up in my butt no so I
would at nighttime it was when I used to
sneak out of my home that makes a had
and I would come back from hanging out
whatever and then I would have to pee
really badly but I didn't want to wake
up my parents so I would pee in the
backyard and then sneak back into the
window wait you didn't sneak in and then
P cuz you're afraid to wake them up that
makes sense
what do you snuck out of the house did
you do like super fun brand friendly
things no it definitely not friendly
I pray and Frehley stuff oh I don't get
you're trying to bring me down
jealous of all the I love it I
absolutely love that car
give me and we have another DiGiorno
party because I missed up here when's
the next Ozona party invited bro we're
talking about juste a wife is invited
you're not oh man well I'm gonna hide
the truck and then I'll show up at all
another hey wait I'm gonna you guys are
cool drama no wait I don't really know
[Music]